if you want to hear about the secret
murder plot hidden within the world of
look-see stick around to the end of this
video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you yourself cannot release then it
will come to take a piece what is it
talking about
I'm not holding on to anything it
couldn't be talking about releasing
these 58 things you missed from Creek
TVs hit web series look see could it
okay fine I was gonna keep them to
myself but here they are 58 things you
missed before we get started you'll
definitely want to have seen the kripp
TV web series look see so if you haven't
gotten to see it yet click your tap
right here to watch it before coming
back to this video one of the things
that's never fully answered in Luxy is
what the extent of the tight killer
characters supernatural powers actually
is in other words how is looksie able to
use its abilities to punish its victims
starting in episode 1 it looks at first
glance like look see has the ability to
teleport or at least move extremely fast
to catch people who aren't able to
release for example at the very
beginning this woman runs into the
bathroom as if she's already been chased
then checks all three stalls to confirm
she's alone she must do this because she
already has an idea of what looks he is
capable of and wants to make sure she's
alone by checking every inch of the
bathroom she's hiding out in eventually
she decided to hide in the middle stall
now focus on this crack in the door
did you catch that the creature crosses
from left to right the only door in and
out of the bathroom is on the far right
side so how did it get to the left side
so quickly on top of that the shoes end
up appearing under the stall back over
on the left side the constant movement
puts the viewers on edge by breaking the
rules of space we're never sure where
the look-see might appear there's
another example of its uncanny movement
ability at the end when it appears in
the toilet seat behind her in episode 2
it warps out of Daniels bedroom then
warps in and out of the shower area
to kill the woman Daniel's having an
affair with then in episode 3 it shows
up behind a bedroom door how is it able
to do this is it teleportation episode 5
offers a couple of possibilities to
solving the secret first we see the
creature double itself Daniel shows up
at the hospital but soon sees that he's
also a victim of luck see when he grabs
her knee pause it right there it's looks
he's hand with Daniels arm I would infer
that whenever we see someone who's died
come back to life look she is behind it
but looks he also seems to possess the
ability to duplicate itself because
right here dead Daniel and Luxio appear
side by side you can pause it to where
they're on-screen at the same time there
could be multiple copies of looksie
helping create the illusion of
teleportation but that doesn't explain
how luke's he appears in rooms that the
characters have already proven to be
empty episode 5 may offer an answer for
that as well the protagonist has an
opportunity to attack looksie but
despite having no eyes it's extremely
fast reflexes and movement speed help it
get away
my theory is that looks he has the
ability to move so fast that if you let
it out of sight for a moment it can rush
to another location and it can do this
all very quickly and quietly that's not
the only ability it has them it's super
flexible enough to bend down so its head
is down by its feet it's strong enough
to rip off body parts and contort
corpses and they can open and close
doors without touching them honestly it
seems like he can do whatever it wants
and tends to just toy with its victims I
wouldn't be surprised if we
seen the full extent of what it's
capable of yet despite all of this it
does seem fairly easy to hurt look see
it gets injured when it's hand gets
slammed in the door in episode 2 and
once she stabs it in the head in episode
5 it doesn't stay down for long though
later tossing the bloody fork back to
mock her now that we've covered what the
monster can do and let's take a look at
why each character receives the same
notes if you yourself can not release
then it will come to take a piece let's
break it down episode by episode the
first woman won't release herself from a
marriage that's clearly gone south if
you've ever heard the term take her hand
in marriage you'll know why it's
symbolic that her hand was taken from
her and similarly if you've ever heard
the term as she walked out on her
husband that could also be the reason
her legs are broken she's one of only
two characters to survive an encounter
so it's possible that looks he's
actually giving her a second chance so
that once her legs do heal she'll
appreciate them enough to put them to
good use and walk out on her man another
episode shows her writing tons of notes
for other victims which makes me think
that there's a jigsaw ask apprenticeship
going on here like if you survive your
game you'll become a stronger person for
it and help set up games for someone
else
in fact the themes in this series aren't
too dissimilar from those in the Saw
franchise in the next episode we see why
she needs to leave her marriage because
her husband is seeing another woman the
adulterous woman wants more than to
simply sleep with Daniel though she's
got her eyes set on being the
replacement she wants to be the girl
whose face appears next to him in that
photo which is why looks he takes away
her head she needed to release her idea
of being with a married man there's
evidence around the house that this is
the home of a man in a committed
relationship the obvious one is the
picture on the bathroom mirror but she
also steps outside playfully where you
can see two heart-shaped chairs in the
bathroom a double showerhead is
installed one for the taller man and one
for his wife there's more back story on
why Daniel cheats on his wife later in
the series but for now let's move on to
episode 3 the character and this one
needs to release his obsession with his
deceased daughter who drowned in an
accident
his release would be to move on with his
life we see him in a sad state preparing
his daughters would be 13th birthday
cake and eating it by himself while
flipping through an album of old photos
this isn't just a one-time thing for his
daughter's birthday
he still has cupboards locked up
something that you would do to prevent a
child from getting in and seemingly he
hasn't touched the daughter's room he
wants nothing more than to embrace his
child again
so looksie removes his arms while
leaving his hands and twist his head
around to signify that he needed to turn
around and stop looking to the past
episode 4 is where things really get
interesting it opens with the death of a
high school student at harbor high
shortly thereafter we discovered that
they're already 12 victims being
investigated and this kid is the 13th
pausing the video to read the small text
uncovers the reason for the deaths
medication found poisoned laced over the
counter this is the biggest event that's
happened so far in the series this
headline confirms a mass murder plot and
all signs point to it being someone
other than look see there's even a
possibility that it goes much bigger
than what showed on screen if medication
was laced at a pharmacy there are
probably other adult victims that we
haven't seen yet this community has a
mass murderer on its hands
it's no wonder it looks he's drawn to
this area because there must be
countless people who need to release
this is actually where the whole saga
begins the series presents the episodes
in an order that lets us discover more
about the monster with each passing
episode the Crypt TV later released a
special super cut with the episodes
arranged in chronological order it
starts with this funeral episode which
tells us a lot about why there's so much
grief in this community the reason that
looks he comes here and pushes these
people to release it is here that we see
the beginnings of Daniel and his wife's
relationship falling apart I would
assume that they're at the funeral
because one of the 13 children who were
poisoned was theirs and losing their
child puts a huge strain on their
relationship it's here that Daniel meets
the woman who he later has the affair
with often in times of crisis it's
comforting to turn to someone you can
relate to and unfortunately in this case
they develop a relationship Daniel's
wife finds out and that leads to the
next episode chronologically where looks
he forces her to release in the bathroom
not long after we have the infidelity
episode and my theory is it's both
Daniel and that the affair woman who are
punished in this one when she gets out
of the bathroom and Daniels nowhere to
be found
because looksie has already taken him
removing his eyes because it was his
wandering eyes that initially led him to
check out this woman and by the way it
may not have been the first time that
his eyes were up to no good
later that night the wife wakes up in
the hospital and tries to kill looksie
but she's unsuccessful it's unclear how
much time passes until the final episode
in the chronology where Luke's he
returns to punish the lingering father
at the end of which Daniels wife has
become look-sees note writing Lackey so
if she's been the one writing notes then
who wrote her note on the bathroom stall
door that's also answered in episode 4
the short answer is it's this guy but
let's take it back to the start of
episode 4 the kid who dies in the
opening shot is featured on the memorial
where we saved this photo of him I'm
assuming that's his sister her name is
Gretchen Walt turns out she's a cop and
she's tasked with cleaning up
markers her release is going to involve
moving on after the tragedy just like
the guy from the third episode but in
her case she wants to do a little bit of
investigation on her own and stuck to
snoop around the school when something
out of the ordinary happened and she
sees one of the kids who is covered in
the she it's back up and moving around
as we know this is a manipulation of
look see after coming face to well after
hid encounter with look see we finally
meet the mystery man and he actually
saves her but ends up getting picked off
by the creature
Gretchen actually survives but this man
is forced to leave the message in the
bathroom before eventually killing
himself at the start of episode five we
don't know a whole lot about his
character so all I can do is theorize
about what he needed to release his
death may not be the best place to look
for clues like I did with the others
because it would appear that he
committed suicide to escape the torment
of look scene so he got out on his own
terms all we know was he was in the
school that night after the murders
sneaking around backstage you may not
have noticed this in the background but
when Holtz surveys with her flashlight
you can spot a girl facing the wall my
first inclination that is that the
mystery man is doing something to her
when he notices holes and picks her out
he also makes a brief appearance at the
funeral looking down on the crowd from
above before making his exit at this
point he's looking like the top suspect
to be the murderer my guess is he has
some kind of grudge against society and
his release would simply be to let go
what he ends up doing instead is killing
dozens of people showing up to the
funeral to watch the parents suffer then
returning to the scene of the crime for
some more foul play he knows looks he's
gonna do something horrible to him so he
ends his life on his own terms to get
away and that's the last death we see on
screen because the married woman ends up
getting away at the end of episode 5 but
that doesn't mean that the fifth episode
doesn't still offer some clues about
Luke see there are elements that keep
popping up for each victim
for example the victims always seem to
be around flowers when looksie attacks
they can be seen beside the hospital bed
the flower wallpaper in episode 3 also
flowers on the cups on the jars on the
toilet in episode 2 and again on the
wallpaper in episode 1 the wallpaper
design resembles the cracks in the walls
in episode 4 and the newspaper article
in that episode encourages people to
bring flowers back in the first episode
a butterfly design is seen on looksie
shoes so look see could represent a
butterfly going around from flower to
flower or victim the victim
spreading its message there are some
other similarities in the attacks but
the meanings if any may not be as clear
for example I saw an apple and banana on
the scene of two of the attacks and two
of them take place around 65 that could
have something to do with the stopwatch
which comes in the shape of an eye one
feature that looks seem noticeably does
not have the stopwatch could be a
countdown for how long someone has to
release before they're punished but
those details are yet to be seen one
conclusion I would like to make however
is that the body parts that looksie
collects many people make up in the
composition of look see looking at its
design look see does seem to be stitched
together from a bunch of various body
parts and we see the main characters own
hand used to give for the stopwatch near
the end as I mentioned look see is
prominently lacking eyes considering its
name is a portmanteau of the words look
and the see the two verbs most commonly
associated with eyes it will be
interesting to see what lips he ends up
doing with Daniels eyes that brings me
to my last thing you miss which is this
title card asking about what
happen next that may be the end of
season 1 but it appears that there are
and more plans to bring Lucy back for a
second season you don't want to miss out
on what happens next so I'll leave you
this link to subscribe to clip TV to
stay up to date on look-see and plenty
of other great short horror content let
me know some of your own theories about
Lucy and where you think the series will
go from here in the comments I will see
you in the next one assuming any both
survive